hallo ihr lieben wer vanille mag der
wird das folgende rezept auch schon
kennen und lieben wir machen dem ich
heute vanillekipferl das ist so total
typisch für den winter und mein rezept
ist anfänger freundlich und gelingt auf
jeden fall und jetzt zeige ich euch die
zutaten für unseren weg benötigen wir
zimmer war mit butter mehl gemeinde
mandeln oder haselnüssen außerdem
puderzucker und vanillezucker und später
benötigen wir noch mal butter zucker und
vanillezucker und jetzt bereiten wir
zuallererst dafür nehme ich meine fünf
zutaten und gibt dir einfach auf die
saubere arbeitsfläche die ärmel
hochkrempeln mit sauberen händen und
dann können wir das alles zu einem teig
zusammen kneten
[Musik]
und bei mir funktioniert das am besten
wenn die butter zimmer war mist viele
quälten den mittag auch mit ganz kalter
butter aber ich habe sie lieber zimmer
war man hat man nicht dieses stückchen
im teig und das lässt sich alles ein
bisschen einfacher verkneten
und ihr könnt also die trockenen zutaten
einfach auf die arbeitsfläche geben eine
mulde bilden mutter rein um die jetzt
einfach alles kneten
[Musik]
so nach wenigen minuten ist der teig
fertig natürlich geht es auch mit der
küchenmaschine aber wofür es geht auch
ohne
und nicht jeder achte küchenmaschine zu
hause jetzt müssen wir den teig in
frischhaltefolie einwickeln und drückten
dann immer schön flach denn da muss
jetzt richtig schön durch können und die
flacher der wird umso kürzer ist die
wartezeit
und der eingewickelte teil kommt jetzt
in den kühlschrank für 30 bis 60 minuten
bis der teig richtig schön hart geworden
ist unser weg ist jetzt richtig schön
bat mein herz auch und ich werde jetzt
erstmal nur die hälfte nehmen und die
andere hälfte packe ich ein und gibt es
wieder zurück in den kühlschrank
weil das in der zwischenzeit ja dann
nicht weich werden muss so einmal die
hälfte setzten wieder einpacken und ab
in den kühlschrank übernimmst pauli du
jetzt nehmen wir uns die hälfte des
teigs und kneten sie ganz kurz mit den
händen noch mal einigermaßen geschmeidig
muss wirklich nur ganz kurz sein denn
unsere hand ist schon warm genug oder
nicht schmilzt noch mal so ein bisschen
die butter
als nächstes müssen wir uns einen strand
ausrollen aus dem teig und da könnt ihr
euch gerne ein bisschen mehr auf die
arbeitsfläche geben dann geht es sind
einfacher und danach zeige ich euch nie
das ganze einteilt
[Musik]
ihr könnt auch zwei stränge übereinander
legen parallel dann könnte immer zwar
auf einmal durchschneiden und ich nehme
jetzt immer sieben zentimeter lange
kipfer
ihr könnt auch größer oder kleiner
machen ist vollkommen euch überlassen
ihr müsst es auch nicht genau abmessen
wenn ich solche mit kindern bagdad die
einfach so ein
dann müsste da jetzt nicht so
perfektionistisch sein
[Musik]
und als nächstes super easy nehmen wir
uns einfach nur einen von diesen kleinen
streng legen uns die auf unsere
arbeitsfläche da braucht ja auch kein
mehl und dann einfach die äußeren seiten
richtig schön nochmal etwas dünner
rollen und dann wieso kleine monde
einfach formen und so kommt es dann aufs
backblech ich habe jetzt eine dauer back
folie ihr könnt aber auch ein backpapier
nehmen
[Musik]
so ein blech ist schon mal fertig und
das kommt jetzt in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 190 grad ober und
unterhitze für zehn minuten es kann sein
dass es eine minute länger oder kürzer
dauert sie dürfen auf jeden fall nicht
zu braun werden und ich zeige euch
gleiches endergebnis für die
vanillekipferl sind jetzt aus dem ofen
und brauner als das dürfen sie auch
nicht sein also sind hier unten schön
braun und hier wirklich nur an den
spitzen und jetzt kommt der nächste
schritt die sind auch noch warm die sind
gerade mal 23 minuten abgekühlt wir
müssen auch noch warm weiterverarbeiten
und zwar gebe ich jetzt erstmal
vanillezucker zum puderzucker anrühre
das gut um
und als nächstes ist nehmen wir uns die
warmen kipferl trugen sie richtig
ordentlich ins puderzucker und dann ist
es schon fertig und das muss auch
erfolgen solange das noch warm ist dann
bildet sich nämlich so eine richtig
schöne puderzucker haut
[Musik]
mein zweites blech ist jetzt auch schon
fertig da muss ich mich gleich beeilen
denn es ist ganz wichtig dass sie so
landes die noch warm sind eingetaucht
werden eben diese puderzucker masse und
wenn ihr die dann fertig habe dann
erhalten die vier bis sechs wochen
wichtig ist dass sie die luftdicht
verpackt zum beispiel in einer gebäck
dose und dann habt ihr ganz lange freude
damit ich wünsche euch jetzt viel spaß
im nachbacken die genauen mengenangaben
stehen hier unten in der infobox profits
unbedingt aus schickt mir eure fotos mit
dem hashtag ligges kitchen auf instagram
ansonsten hinterlasst dem video gerne
ein bisschen nach oben es folgen noch
ganz viele tolle winterliche
weihnachtliche rezepte also abonniert
diesen kanal kostenlos aktiviert die
glocke dann verpasst er auch nichts mehr
und ich sag bis zum nächsten mal auf die
diskussion macht das richtig lecker
[Musik]